[Music]
okay
who's gonna do this last time you did it
you gotta back up and let me do it no
last time you did it
wasn't it you you jumped in i was like
wow good job no
i i did it two weeks ago you did it last
week at nine oh for real okay go ahead
hey guys and welcome back to frenemies
today we are doing the presidential
fitness test frenemy style
wait it's not the presidential fitness
test well whatever version of the
presidential fitness has
could you pass the presidential fitness
test why is it called the president like
the president is gonna [ __ ] if i could
do push-ups
you know what i mean not our current one
definitely can't do push-ups
joe biden yeah he challenges people i
feel like he could do something
yeah he's some piece of fit over here i
like him but yeah
why would you [ __ ] on our dear president
okay no i'm kidding
so um and we should just say start the
show by a hashtag stop the asian hate we
need to just
say what stop the asian hate more people
need to talk about getting animations
no it's like a tren it's a hashtag right
now and i feel like it needs to bring
more awareness
what are people doing today there's a
lot of asian hate crimes happening right
now and
there are in our country it's a huge
thing right now and
i think 3 000 in the past crimes
people who are like well you know who
started it trump he ignited not to make
a politic
oh because because of that you think oh
no it is like
especially specifically older who's
going to hate on who's going to he has
the facts but especially elders
i think seven percent are elders that
are getting like people are just beating
the [ __ ] out of them and they're dying
what who's doing this it's a huge thing
right now and it's stuffed asian
talking about who's doing that who's got
time to hate on asians when there's so
many jews walking around no if you want
to be an ally
what jews oh people love jews now it's
super trendy
although that girl got fired for being a
jew remember from the star wars thing
there was a girl that was jewish and got
fired
i don't think she got fired for being
jewish i think she got fired for saying
oh no no she's i don't think she's
jewish what she said was that
she's not she said wearing a mat or she
said being a conservative is like being
jews during the holocaust which is
kind of a dumb [ __ ] statement and she
got fired for that that and many other
things
so she but she's a jewish person herself
i don't
believe a jewish person would say that
but i could be wrong i mean
[Music]
she's not jewish she got fired though
i'm pretty confident
so what's going on with the asians what
do we know about the asians to be an
ally to the aapi which is the um
asian american pacific islanders you
just have to raise awareness like if
you're in the workplace about it you
should have like conversations about it
ask like
people if they need like you know
because it's a trying time right now so
people are suggesting so do i need to go
up to asians and ask if they're okay
they need a break oh if they need a
break what does that mean
okay i thought it's on the website this
is not me saying this but say what
suggestion yeah i'm
supposed to cover asians at the
workplace we're all [ __ ] tired
first of all they're going through a
trying time what are you i thought i
thought old asians were getting beat up
stress if you're well we won't say that
but stress if something's coming through
it's like you know they're going okay so
go you telling me to i don't know that
asian people want people going up to
them asking if they're okay that seems
kind of patronizing but like i read on
the aapi website that like if
you can offer your service of like
taking over their job temporarily like
if they need help with a project because
there's
they're they have to go to protest right
now dan is this this seems so outrageous
what you're trying to say
the website today oh my god so i'm
supposed to go cover for
for asians so they can go protest walk
down the street and worry about getting
them
listen i'm not no i'm just i'm just
wondering what i need to do to help
support my asian brothers and sisters
so stop asian hate okay read it since
kova 19 anti-aging hate crimes have
increased by
nineteen hundred percent in the united
states nearly three thousand reported
anti-asian hate incidents were reported
in over 47 states and the district of
columbia
seven point three percent of those
reports counted the most vulnerable
elderly asians as the victims and many
crimes
go unreported or not possible if you're
actually doing this you are beyond sick
and you know why people are doing this
it's because all
trump and all of his conservative allies
are going around saying wuhan virus in
china created it and all that
it's just pure [ __ ] racism xenophobic
[ __ ] it's kind of like when the blm
movement really like made such a
difference like people just need to like
raise more awareness here it is from the
website non-asian american friends and
colleagues can show support by checking
in with aapi peers
showing they're aware of the news
demonstrating their well-being asking
someone and opening up
i feel like they're feeling like is
there anything i can do for you i feel
like they're emotional
there's not enough asians i feel like
they're talking on behalf of every asian
and i don't know
like i'm just speaking for myself i'm
not asian but like i don't want people
coming up to be like are you okay how
are you doing can i do it it's like
patronizing
that's like saying how i was doing it if
i need some help you want everybody to
do
i need some help okay well well you're
i would love it if they could you know
like if people ask me like hey i'll take
over this assignment for today i'd be
like thank you
everybody's worried about you don't
worry not about me because i'm
like i'm i'm like i'm white and like
there's one right
is that it is wasp anyways is that a
derogatory statement
white anglo white anglo-saxon protestant
making is that a and raising awareness
about this is the main issue we need to
do so then we're good we're doing that
you don't have to go up to a random age
on the street and be like can i hear you
don't
i would say don't do that that's weird
but raising awareness also during
the big platform i just wanted to stay
at the top of the show how many asians
have you
gone up to and asked if they're okay be
honest
i'm gonna put it out there if you're
asian and need my help please
email me because i help everybody but
specifically this week i would like to
help
asian american or pacific islanders in
our united states specifically san
francisco and la there's a lot of these
hate violent crimes if you need help
if you need like a job direction
placement anything like that email me
well i can i can't believe there's
actually people doing i mean maybe we're
too sheltered here in l.a because people
are generally more like educated than
most people
i never heard i didn't know people were
actually doing this is shocking to me
the problem mainstream media is not
talking about well what can i do you
can't fix [ __ ]
awareness you can't fix dumb yes you
look out for these i agree
if i saw it on the street i would i
would do a fl i would i would
sacri i would um but you don't want to
come up against angry
i don't think you're going to be able to
fight against anybody i would do
anything i would do anything for them
i'll do anything for the asians
i just hashtag southeast do some
research raise awareness in the
workplace just say how important
is this people are i mean this is
horrific it's so sad
it's so sad it's so it's just so
are dying and they're not being
classified as hate crimes that's what's
so annoying oh
actually yeah it should be classified as
a hate yeah they're just like saying
like oh this person just died on the
street like casually when they got the
show
well when people commit a hate crime the
punishment is more severe so they
definitely hate crimes that's what i'm
saying like no one's getting people
aren't getting punished for these things
like it's insane like it just needs to
be
talked about more it's it was trending
on tick tock but i do think it should be
trending everything we did good we're
trending it
okay so what is the point so it's good
save the agents
hashtag okay
i was thinking save the whales why were
you thinking back
because you're looking at me oh my god
you literally were like i was thinking
save the whale
no it's just saved the i wasn't trying
to call you
you know well would you be so mad if
people were trying to save you you said
you want people checking in on you i'm
not an actual whale
okay save trisha baby we have so much to
cover so too because
okay wait let me tell you let me just
say slow down i just want to like get
back
that's our sponsor today what's our
sponsor save they stop the
asian heat stop the haitian eight what
stop the asians stop the asians
okay
today we are doing the physical tests
that everybody
was super excited about myself too we're
gonna see
if anybody first of all can do a pull-up
we're seeing easy anybody could do
push-ups we're having a running
competition we're having a jump rope
competition
i trained basketball did you i tried i
knew you did i did
i swear i didn't train because i want to
go on raw yeah same because i'm actually
going to start training we have our
workout equipment coming this week so
i'm actually going to start training so
i wanted to see how good i was
pre-training so maybe in a month we'll
go back and oh you want to do it
rechecking yeah
that's interesting so stay tuned we're
just gonna chitchat a little bit then
we're gonna head out to the uh
hit the irons also the um challenge is
from frenemies i'm saying that right
here somebody tried to debate that it
wasn't
it is i don't so wait there's i was on
xanax during those episodes and i was
like um
because i don't remember doing that
because you know what the stuff you
still do it though if you see me in the
street i will do video shout outs for
your friends whatever
don't ask me to go um because i don't do
that anymore like that was like the next
moment
no you still do it definitely i
literally hear you do it every episode
and i just don't say anything because
it's like i don't want to beat the dead
horse but you literally
mmm everything not the people love it no
it was a different time so do you want
you just did you literally just did it
you went it was a different time
you literally just did it can we have
the credit for that on tick tock how
come no one's taking doesn't it
it should be hashtag front of me every
time someone doesn't inside the
challenge it should be the front of me
challenge
i mean i'm complimented that that we've
broken
into popular media in that way i didn't
tell you we stopped the mcdonald's on
our break on the way over here
you somehow beat me you got a chicken
sandwich they had a new one out today
and i was so excited
sorry we should have brought i thought
you guys were gonna stop too otherwise i
would have brought you food i'm sorry
well i can't eat bread i'm on the keto
i know i would about damn food because i
was like [ __ ] cause he texts us you guys
aren't here i was like [ __ ] they didn't
stop i thought you guys were all
stopping for food at your own leisure so
sorry my bad oh it's fine you don't have
to worry about us
no it's like so rude and i i love the
coke there coke has uh mcdonald's has
better coke you know why they pay extra
for machines to get the balance between
the syrup it's the perfect blend
oh so the coke is so good i couldn't
leave it in the car i was trying to like
hide and it's that diet
this is diet i love it okay i just want
to make sure
i also brought like snacks so if you
want oh
trisha that is not diaphone yo bro it
matches you it looks like you
it's a snowball but i brought you a keto
snack these are what i was telling you
about oh no way
oh my god peach ring wait wait wait this
is not
candy trisha what you don't eat the
whole thing
trisha this has carbs and a shitload of
sugar no
it's no sugar it's fruit what do you
mean
it's peach rings it's fruit sugar no
sugar
keto is no sugar sugar
this is not keto so excited for you okay
you want our cupcakes but just so you
know
snowball this is the how is this is not
same sugar okay i thought eating was
like
this ain't in any diet i'll just put it
there
this is not any diet and neither is it
this is just fruit it's just
i can't eat fruit on keto do you see how
many carbs are in it
for our workout today pink gatorade
and a pink monster oh my god you're
going to be
you're going to be gaining a lot of
weight during this i need makeup
girl you are eating a hostess cupcake
that's energy
that's like straight out of the meme
hole right there bringing it with you
but okay whatever
i guess you're done being fat well i'm
trying honestly congrats
well hold on i i lost a pound and a half
so you guys know
amazing honestly because i've been doing
keto for about four days
and exercising trying to exercise every
night not a lot but you know like 20
minutes on the
peloton mm-hmm just a little something
that's good
you can eat that before quietly okay no
go for it i'm just so
hungry i only had a chicken sandwich no
fries i wanted the fries so bad
i'm hungry dude anyway the keto is just
like basically all protein so
let me let me witness this
jesus christ so when are you
are you i i don't i'm not going to keep
bringing up that you need to die or not
that you need to but
i thought we were going to do it
together when did we ever agree to that
well i thought it'd be fun you start
losing weight so i feel so embarrassed
to sit next to you that i have to start
losing weight too
okay until they can tell the difference
between our sizes and i start getting
bigger than you
do you think we should have some kind of
weight loss competition
because that would be fun that would be
maybe motivating even
i think that's gonna be worse for me i'm
gonna sabotage myself because yeah once
you get left behind or something then it
gets really
uncomfortable surprised to lose weight
than girls so two
so two statistics what statistics
the ones where you're
anyways so we're getting into that
because we have a lot we have so much
things to talk about yeah okay okay
so first of all i know we've talked
about david dobrik a lot
but i just have proof okay proof that he
watches our podcast
proof that he watches our podcast
well here well i'm gonna show it to you
now i want your reaction so here it is
can you see that
poor semen can cost up to four point
seven million dollars we had a
ben shapiro uh uh impersonator colin
and he made this joke oh sorry cat's out
of the bag
i don't know who that is okay well
anyway he made a joke about how
horse semen is the most expensive liquid
on the planet
and so now watch of course it can cost
up to four point seven million dollars
it is actually the most expensive liquid
you can buy
liquids in the world this is [ __ ]
amazing is horse semen
well you probably already know about
this jay i know a lot about semen
but a gallon of horse semen can go for
four point seven million dollars
horses excuse me wait is this like up to
4.7 million
popular no we just wrote that joke you
wrote the joke for the bench appear
impersonator
it wasn't on news or anything like you
could google no yeah we wrote the joke
we i'm not going to take credit it's not
even real it's not a real fact
it is a real fact okay but he did it six
days later how are you
you can't let this is fact no he's
obsessed with people talking about him
they always got some in the group oh
this person said that he knows
everything he just doesn't have to
acknowledge it
because he's how did you upload a video
five hours ago
she just uploaded video five butter
noodles so anyway
proof that david dilbrick is watching so
hi david time to apologize to seth
[ __ ]
yes horaceman is very expensive where'd
you learn that did you know that
horsesemen is the most expensive liquid
on the planet why
glue well because good horses good
stallions have like
good ass ratings glue what the [ __ ] kind
of glue do you buy
what kind of [ __ ] glue do you buy for
five million dollars blue is made from
horses
horses the [ __ ] does that have to do
with horse semen i don't know if that's
the part that's making the glue they
breed
racing horses like like prize horses
so if you have like buttercup who's like
won all the hor the horse races then his
jizz is worth like
tons of money bro jizz that's great
golden jizz
give it up you know what all you gotta
do is like even privately apologize
success like don't ignore his phone
calls like just maybe talk to me like
that was messed up like
also you like just just acknowledge it
like it's just not that hard like it's
insane
it's so insane and probably people
saying oh she's weaponizing like
i'm not it's called raising awareness
because like imagine if that was a girl
imagine that was anyone else imagine if
you did that
to a girl or something like that and
like you force your kiss on somebody
else and force your mouth on somebody
else like that would be
like you literally go to jail and he
doesn't even know i mean i
i can't believe that no i still can't
believe that nobody's picking this up
no news outlets all these [ __ ] like
variety and
insider and all these [ __ ] they
write about anything is picking it up
did you they tweeted me they're like you
said no one was taking the david over
okay seriously we are
email us for details and they email me
they didn't publish it yet i don't think
so but i think they're like
good because it's like they write about
the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] they'll write
about david dobrik's new house is
amazing
all this dumb [ __ ] right but like they
won't actually write about anything real
about this story
philip defranco i love you phillip but
um
you guys put me in another thumbnail
because you're a [ __ ] coward for not
talking about this
and you too i think keemstar is not
covering just because he doesn't want to
give us props
no they're just like i don't know i
think keemstar keemstar doesn't want to
say there was an
ethan conducted an interview with seth
that would [ __ ] sear his heart
but like it is a white male club right
like it's like
philip defranco keemstar david like
they're all in this like club they're
all except like
if this was again anyone else like if it
was i don't think it's
i think it just has to do with they
don't want to go against the grain
exactly that's what i'm saying it's
nothing to do with like privilege for
sure it hasn't for sure
they just they don't want to deal with
the backlash of cut of doing a negative
story about david that's all
it's so gross to me you know what but
like i've learned from anything
especially with
people that have like i've been abusive
and like essay and all that stuff like
that
it's like it comes back around
eventually like you know look at bill
cosby it took him like 60 years
to get justice served but it does happen
and
at least well i don't think by the way
back up back up he's not like
as far as we know he's not yeah i mean
but what he's not like a serial
no it's really traumatizing what he did
though i mean i agree
but i've been in a similar situation i'm
just saying like tone it down a little
bit
no where like unwanted advances towards
me made me feel some type of way for
years that i didn't know that even
happened so he had
now dealing with all the internet
thinking he's a problem definitely
endured a lot of [ __ ] okay
so the very basic minimum and this helps
anyone that's been through something
like acknowledgement and apology goes
so long even if it's a [ __ ] fake
whatever like
just acknowledging that like you did
something wrong and you apologize like
that's insane that he can't do that to
me like the very
bare minimum you can do it to you
this person is saying like and now he's
all these people calling him a liar and
then he went along with it oh we can
prove this like it's just
it's so it's so disgusting not to go
through all that i was curious i just
went to
dramaalert to see if he had made a david
dobrik uh video
and to my surprise his like second most
recent video says david dobrik in the
title so i clicked on it and all the
comments are like you're gonna talk
about david's bed but not david getting
cancelled
if it was anyone other than ethan that
shed light on it you'd be all over it
exactly as i [ __ ] said
he literally did a drama alert about his
[ __ ] bed and not the fact that
someone did a
full-on interview saying it was essay
twice by him like keemstar how are you
going to purport to do the news just
because you want to avoid
like giving like mentioning that i
conducted the interview you [ __ ]
ghoul
no it's like he has no interest in doing
the right thing and this is absolute
proof of it
and philip defranco i think phil duran's
a good guy but he's empowered
right now oh he's a coward and
everything i i don't think i dislike
anyone as much as they know
you always say that no it's not a hatred
okay who do you hate more him or jack's
film jackson
of course yeah you see easy sorry you're
right
exactly that's what i thought with him
oh that tweet was good
yeah i mean philip defranco come on how
was how
that's the thing everybody wrote about
david's bed
it's like okay cool he bought a [ __ ]
big bed who the [ __ ] cares
it's the most insane thing i've ever
seen david has a drinking fountain that
spits out kool-aid cool that's awesome
good luck cleaning that you think that's
gonna have mold on nobody's gonna use
that
after a [ __ ] day it's disgusting
regardless
no mention of the firsthand account on
video
of someone getting essay twice by him
for profit and then him refusing to pay
them no mention of that but he's got a
big bed
it's so gross to me it's so it's so
gross and
i don't know it's like it's like
screaming into like literally like a
pillow right
like i was watching the um woody allen
docky series last night oh was it good i
want to watch it and
yeah but it again not to compare the two
to extreme but like his daughter said
this in 94
in 2004 yeah and nothing happened and
she goes dirtier than me two
people scarlett johansson was still
working with her young all these people
are yeah he's still working
could you imagine no no he has a film
right now on production in europe a huge
budget
i mean he made a huge he made a movie
with larry david like
in 2009 scoop yeah it was a huge movie
like no he's still working bro oh people
like
no he may be no i was just reading about
it he he can't get distribution in the
united states anymore
i think now came out look up the year it
came out in 2009 like that was a huge
movie
i mean he's old as [ __ ] how old is he's
gonna be barely hanging on at this point
i think he's at 85. i'm pretty sure i
read that
yeah that story i'm gonna watch the duck
better than that it's a four-part
docu-series it's on hbo like
let's just be honest i'm not saying
david dobrik is a serial
[ __ ] he's done enough like he owes
some acknowledgement of what's going on
here
he definitely owes that i feel like i'm
getting a firsthand account of how hard
it is
to come out as like even in today's like
super woke me too [ __ ]
like in even with us amplifying it as
much as possible
the fact that i feel we feel like we're
talking into an empty void
like is is absolutely is is so [ __ ]
like uh
maddening and it's so again i'm not
comparing it but i just related so much
when
when mia farrow when she she talked
about the story
they labeled it as oh she's a bitter
ex-wife because he like
married her daughter i was like yeah
because
her daughter got abused and then the
other one did too at like 10 and
molested like sexually abused like it's
it's documented there's footage and this
new one it's on hbo this new
series that is that's a four-part series
you have footage of this like
it's like it's not even just like
believing what people are saying there's
like footage of him i mean inappropriate
with her
he adopted this girl at what age she had
adopted suny with her ex-husband andre
privy or whatever so when did he when
did this girl enter his life like nine
and they're always video
so woody allen raised this girl from
nine years old and then
married her at like 16. right i mean
kiss gloves
but aside from that her other adopted
daughter um dylan farrow
was getting molested for years by woody
allen before sunyi right that's what
they
all said and they're like ah who cares
he's funny or i guess after yeah
yeah but he's pretty funny though yeah
i mean people knew about bill cosby for
a long [ __ ] time too
i mean and she said the same thing she
was it was like screaming like i don't
know what her analogy was but it's the
same thing of like no one cared during
me too like harvey weinstein was kidding
but like what woody allen did was like
it's like their children like it's
insane like it's so
how is it again not to say it's the same
thing because it's not but like
when i was doing that interview with uh
seth i was like this
is cr what i'm hearing is insane and p
and people are i was like david is
definitely gonna have to respond to this
and then fast forward two weeks later
nobody gives a [ __ ]
okay whatever we can't talk about david
frustrating no because you know when i
hear i hate on to talk to you being like
oh trish is just a man better this has
nothing to do with me like i would stick
up for anyone i'm thinking for dylan
perry i'm sticking up for
the you know stop asian hate like i'd
stick up for anyone well it's like well
when i made a
because i made a tick tock where he was
like just
business as usual whatever and i was
like wow i can't believe nobody's
that was crazy but a lot of the comments
were like oh whatever dude [ __ ] you
you're just [ __ ] you're a hater or
you make videos for trisha so you can't
say anything stuff like that
but it's like no all of his fans don't
want to
address the issue that he did these
things no it's like you all want to talk
about this and that's bad so let's just
ignore
an actual like an actual like awful
thing that's like really traumatizing
yeah but also the comparisons is moronic
first of all you've acknowledged all the
things you've done wrong
second of all you've never been to
somebody exactly if i do that but
regardless this conversation is at the
point because we're not even talking
about you we're talking about david you
want to talk about churchill we can do
that and
trust me we've done plenty of that and i
call out trisha every time every chance
i get an opportunity
i know and i have like a problematic
math and this is so different than me
this is so above me and beyond my
issues so it's just like i'm just
showing support because he just doesn't
have as much and i'm glad that you did
the interview and i wasn't even involved
in that that was the h3 podcast and i
was so happy to see
well they reached out to me and i
thought his story was interesting yeah
anyway okay whatever let's move on
okay fashion nova you get any money from
them yet because i'm going to talk about
them right now i haven't gotten paid but
i do have a deal i have a test run with
them
bless you which i it's just in the
contract you cannot say how much
don't i can't tell you but it's it's a
test run where's my [ __ ] passion
well it's for tick-tock i'm killing it
on tick-tock multi-fashion is what sucks
i hate them
i love them they're close to suck they
go for curvy girls up to 5x
third size i wanted to ask you about
this tick tock i saw about fashion nova
um why did fashion nova post this they
posted this photo
so my brain i'm saying do not shop at
fashion nova
i'm saying why you're on the show do not
shop at fashion nova it's [ __ ]
it's fast fashion they make it in china
it's disposable if you can't afford
religion fast fashion is literally the
most polluting one of the biggest
polluters in the whole planet
before it's 70 jeans fashionable offers
them for 12. just buy one instead of
size 20.
bro you know when you're buying jeans
for twelve dollars that somebody's dying
you think everybody can afford to buy
seventy dollar jeans they're not dying
you don't know this they haven't been in
their factory they've been in their
factories in downtown l.a actually
fashion nova is not made in downtown l.a
i've been to the factory ah
fashionable is not made in downtown l.a
six years ago
sorry you don't sell [ __ ] twelve
dollar jeans for for
that's made in america trust me that
[ __ ] is made by children
slaves in china don't sue me please
peace stop the asian heat that's what
i'm saying
stop there you go stop the asian hate
they're the ones [ __ ] having little
kids fingers bleeding all over 12
jeans blood jeans like blood diamonds
blood jeans
i'm just trying to make it clear that
they do not sponsor me
isn't that an abstinent movie blood
diamonds that was a leo movie oh
yeah wasn't there one where he was a
jeweler oh that was yeah
uncut gems have we seen that one they
weren't blood gems though
but it's about blood diamonds right no
oh really no that's not true yikes
dan over here the hot takes do you think
my diamond's a blood diamond
i don't know moses you tell me yeah his
blood and sweat and tears don't work
i know i feel so bad um oh nevermind
it's okay
what do you feel that about it was his
renovation money for his building uh
whatever he doesn't care he's got a
brand new house
[ __ ] his old building look at him he's
so happy look at that smell on his face
you better put a ring on it if you like
it then you better put a ring on it
because this was like my dream ring i
showed an inspiration for and he's like
well he goes i just wanted you to be
like proud of your ring and show it off
you know exactly he knew he had to get
something outraged just to make you
happy could you imagine if i had like no
offense but it was like one carat for me
because i have a big fat finger it would
have looked
like crazy the marriage wouldn't work
i would have bought my own the marriage
would not work if he gave you one carat
diamond i'll tell you right now
be like he's broke [ __ ] him i don't care
i would love to know how much that costs
oh you'll tell me off camera hell yeah
you know how much it cost
yeah yeah because i had to get like we
have six figures at least right
he yeah i don't know don't say anything
i mean it's gotta be at least six
figures i mean i just know how much
diamond like that cost all right
my guess is that i'm just gonna guess i
i don't know how much it cost
so i can't guess it's such an awkward
conversation
really yeah it's great caleb's in one
fashion okay i won't talk about it then
if it makes me uncomfortable but it's
like 250 probably 300.
oh my god don't talk about it i'm just
guessing i don't have any inside info
so what do you make of this fashion nova
posted this girl do you think this is
realistic uh body
goals i don't have audio oh
music oh there was um she was like what
is this why did they post this
what um why did fashion nova post this
wait why
you don't see anything wrong with that
girl's body
that's what everyone looks like on
instagram bro
wait what's wrong with it i'm so
confused she's like heavier
no her body okay let me open the uh
direct that she's heavy at all but
no she's not heavy her body looks like
[ __ ] freak like that is not a real
body
yeah like that in colombia no yeah look
at her ass what the [ __ ] is that there's
no way that's real
her ass is like the size of she's built
like elastigirl
or what's the mom's name yeah elastigirl
on what
incredible incredibles i've never seen
it she's built like a pixar
can get lipo bruh her ass is the size of
her body and head combined
you think that's real it's just
like and look how small her waist is
that is totally like people do get those
bodies
okay her face isn't real i mean she has
like worked on everywhere but doesn't
mean it's not a real person and of
course she probably put in her waist a
little bit like
you cannot you cannot oh crate why are
you this is like the hill you're gonna
this is not a healthy
image to project out to the world i
don't even care
that's what everyone looks like on
instagram i just because i just wanna
[ __ ] on fashion nova because i know we
have
like tension they're getting such a
shout out you're so stupid i don't think
anyone's going to fashion
after this i literally purchased them
even when i'm not sponsored by them
like all year okay go to fashion nova if
you want to be one of the biggest
polluters and buy [ __ ] that will
literally
disintegrate off your body after it gets
washed one time it's fine because it's
only seven bucks for a t-shirt let it
disintegrate yeah and you know that it's
like one of the biggest
right yeah don't breathe don't don't
walk too fast
it'll fall right off your back almost
dan
anyway uh okay so and i was just curious
what you thought because i thought it
was crazy but you think it looks totally
normal which is interesting
i think um and then one other thing i
want to talk about before we get to the
exercising i don't know if you had
something
but we wanted to start doing douche bag
of the month
do you like that
i mean that's like is it too much who's
the douchebag in the month bryce hall
yes you like it love it i
i can't stand bryce hall yeah he's
unbelievable
he's like i can't believe he's a real
person he might be the worst
i think i thought mike was the douchebag
of the day i think well yeah
maybe mike will be douchebag next time i
know what there was another thing we
were gonna talk about
oh that he mike is making a like hype
house with banks
it should be called the essay house like
not to age shame
i'm just saying you know you know just
like oh that's like a lot of
there's not a lot of character i mean
they're like 40 too like do we need
like you know what i mean we're raging
out here at the [ __ ]
the bank sales bro we got a police car
on standby outside because they get
called in three times a night so they
just stake out
can you imagine like and they're older
than you so like imagine like i know
mike is like can you imagine
being like 38 that's like me in like six
years and i'm like let's start up let's
start a [ __ ] clubhouse like
can you live by yourself like he lived
with logan paul logan's moving to puerto
rico and now mike's gonna move in with
banks it's like bro are you scared of
the dark or something
oh jason are you like scared to live by
yourself you [ __ ] little
boy yeah jason said that too he lived
with roommates at 44 45 he lived without
these vlogs that's so embarrassing
like it's so embarrassing and this is so
embarrassing and it just also sounds
like either
there's one it also sounds scammy so if
they're trying to get young influencers
to come live in this house they're going
to take percentage of their money which
don't give anyone a percentage of money
they're not going to do [ __ ] for you
that's how like team 10 always collapsed
because they they get big and they're
like why am i paying this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
true and it's mike maljak it's not even
logan paul like maybe if logan paul had
a hype house okay cool but
mike militech doesn't have clout without
logan paul and faze banks is not your
car i don't know who that is you don't
know what facebook says no
they call them the they call him like
the the holy monk right dan
now what because he's got like a huge
bald spot that he always tries to hide
he's
he he found it he looks like he's right
which is a
big oh yeah he's getting he's phased
he's face up bruh i'm phased up
phase up i'm phased out phase up see you
in the phase
i hear them all the time there's like
phase gains space clout space banks
phase there's so many phases right
my personal favorite is is uh phase date
trigger warning no but what is a phase
why are they called
maybe just bleep the the r word yeah
what's this it's the name of the clan
it's a gaming clan
my my favorite is faze blackout
so they're twitchers they're twitchers
they're gamers they play like cod
i don't know that is either because they
compete in like the professional gaming
set
blake my favorite is uh get a job
well it is their job they make a lot of
money i mean yeah no they're gonna do
but now they're scamming other people
i bet you they scam the phases i bet if
you have to be a phase you have to pay
money to the monk phase or whatever you
just said
he always wear a hat and then apparently
like the hat fell off and he's got a
huge bald spot everyone realized he was
funny it was
a famous incident he got in a fight at a
bar or something
with jake paul's girlfriend yeah it all
happened
it all happened while jake came on our
podcast phrase friar or phrase
phase monk fritz friars
i feel like keemstar would be in on this
too yeah he is he's friends with things
kid that's all keemstars keemstar's face
the [ __ ] up embarrassing like that's so
embarrassing
i'm not a shaming but i'm a shaming like
you're over 35
stop it they're shopping well you say
ace shaming is good when you're like
40 years old and you're hanging out with
like 18 year olds yeah
something like sorry
you're starting a collab house stop it
stop it
you made money you set their baller just
make your money what's the name of the
drug dan it's like it's got like
three-letter acronym
phase ghp is my favorite phase member oh
for sure phase uh
i don't know it seems like it is yeah
ghp phase ghp is my favorite member
what if you have phase at the beginning
of your name and you're over 35 like
stop it like keemstar changes to like
daniel keem or something you know what i
mean like
he's just he's so embarrassing on so
many levels
preach girl they all are okay let's talk
about it
for us oh we're so mature and we have
aged well into our good luck
hey i got my own [ __ ] albums i'm not
scared of the dark same
did you think our house was busy came to
our house this weekend did you think it
was blue oh yeah
we should talk about that i went to your
house that was like some real friendship
and we didn't even tick-tock it or
anything and it wasn't awkward either
like i thought i was gonna be really
awkward and really awkward yeah
we brought theodore we had fun it was
theodore had a really fun time
i had so much fun yeah he was rocking
the house is beautiful i mean it's it's
gorgeous
i'm just i'm really happy for you guys
well once i get like furniture it'll be
really baller and really cool
i feel like you know obviously i was
very skeptical of you guys relationship
like a long time ago when you first
started but i can tell you guys are
really happy and really good for each
other and i just i feel like it's great
i saw moses in a tuk-tuk when you were
like cooking like fried chicken or
something
and i can tell when moses get really
excited about something and i could see
how excited he was about how good the
cooking was he got really excited about
the chicken fried chicken and i thought
that was sweet
yeah no he helps me out yeah the house
is beautiful i mean you guys i mean it's
great i mean it's fantastic look at this
it's amazing we both had no friends our
entire life and we're like
we found a friend i feel like that's me
and hila too
yeah yeah i think that but that's what
i'm saying there's like people who like
love being around their friends you know
like like the phases right they probably
love being friend oriented
right and it's like a frat boy mentality
all those guys for sure
and like i can't be was obviously like
jason to work out because he had all
these friends and his friends were his
priority but like if you find someone
then there's other people who just don't
aren't super friend-oriented it's like
cool to socialize once in a while but
like
if you're like each other's best friends
i'm not hanging out with like someone
every day that's too much for me but
people aren't like that one no i know i
know yeah
friends every day i'm like look if i was
single i'd probably be
you know socializing a lot more if i but
when i was single i didn't need
the same with moses we just know i was
like what would you do if i wasn't here
like if you were single and he's like
i'll just be home working at night and i
think i'm saying well moses has been
single a long time he's used to it
but i feel like yeah i'm just saying
he's this you know
we always say that we always say like we
like we never thought we'd find someone
when i was single it was a long [ __ ]
time ago i was single like in college
though but i would mingle a lot but that
was like the vibe
i was in college yeah but i feel like
you were more social than us like we
didn't maybe talk to anyone
you want to talk about bryce hall being
douchebag of the month or should we save
it yes yes
i feel like maybe we should just get to
the exercising like how long we've been
doing yeah
i want to talk about bryce hall but
before real quick can i just say real
quick
i do think and this is the last thing
i'll talk about and then when we talk
about because i really want to talk
about bracelet
i think i'm getting gripped off with my
adam sandler clothes i posted a photo
the other day and people noticed that my
hemline was round and the one and then
four oh you think you're getting fake
clear dude people are putting up fakes
literally just to scam you i
pay 754 and they're right the hemline is
really different let me show you
and i was like i think i'm gonna be
scammed i'll send it oh do you send it
now to him yeah okay
dudes there's like one dude putting up
fake adam sandler clothes and making
bank office
that's the best thing ever okay i'm
sending this to you okay so so
here's what you bought uh-huh now you're
saying that you don't think this is the
same shirt i thought it was every single
comment came from me and said you're
getting ripped off girl that's a
different hemline
so the bottom of that my shirt goes
rounded now swipe over
and his is straight across hmm
could it be from a different scene maybe
but that's true yours is
totally not straight and the other thing
is those pants fit me to a t i showed
the waist and everything they fit me so
good and everyone's saying adam sandler
is very tall and lanky
he's not tall that's what i didn't think
he's taller than you though and they fit
perf
that well
that um doesn't look like the same shirt
i'm so scared but it could be that i
mean it could be that
well how do you know is there any
authentication like how do you know that
they give you like a wardrobe tag and
then they give you like
where it's from and stuff like what what
is your wardrobe tag
the water page that says like sandler
and then it has like because anyone
could just write sandler on a tag but
yeah is there any do you have any proof
this actually belonged to him
it smells a little bit that's not proof
i did order i spent four thousand
dollars on the happy gilmore jacket the
gold one he wears at the end that's
coming this week
and i spent four thousand dollars on
this jacket that's the most this was
only 7.50 so i was like okay whatever
but i sent four thousand
do you think you have a problem spending
money well not no but i think i'm
worried that i got ripped off with a
happy gilmore jack i just have four
thousand and even more you gotta be if
you don't spend four thousand on that
jacket
are you gonna open like an ad of sandler
wardrobe museum like you know when you
go to like
hard rock cafe they have like outfits
with glass you should do something with
it
because what are you to do just put in
the laundry i mean you can't do that i
just like to wear it for real
what i bet adam thinks that's so weird
oh i was just saying this to moses so
there's a girl and i don't
but she she's like she does so many
techniques i'm a girl okay like give it
a rest but
nice but i love her i don't want
anything but i'm sure he thinks he's
probably stopped
if he knew there was some weird girl
just buying all this [ __ ] and wearing it
it's still wearing it i think that would
creep him out
like have it be a fan of the film be a
fan put it up frame it whatever but the
fact that you're wearing it
i think is unsettling i just like that
he has but it's funny also
but it's not even about that like i
honestly like wearing it because i feel
like some of his energy is coming into
me
are you just trying to be funny because
i do think it's funny no actually
not at all actually not funny at all i
am so
inspired by him because he put so many
jewish things throughout his movies
stop no he was what that word
why is that a reason to admire him i
thought you could say he's funny he's a
good writer
no he puts jewish references in his film
jewish person that put so many jew
references in all every single every
single movie he makes a jewish reference
okay well let's cancel woody on we're in
antwerp
listen listen it's fun it's fine that
you like them for that reason it's just
not what i expected
he he takes his kids to his daughter's
hebrew school
that's fine it's just not what i
expected you to be praying
what
so you're a fan because he sends his
kids to hebrew school it seems weird
no proud to be jewish his wife converted
for him that means he's a hardcore jew
if he has his wife convert
i respect it he's funny he's successful
i want to be on that level of adam
sandler and netflix like i don't
i want to just be him and i think his
energy radiates to the close and i don't
try and be funny because it's not funny
who thinks
no one's like being like this is amazing
you're so brilliant at buying adam
sandler as well why i think that's why
people like it
no but his body type is very similar no
it's funny that you're willing to spend
so much money for something so trivial
that's what's funny you get adam
sandler's clothes and then you wear it
and it's like why did you spend two
thousand dollars on this shirt
just to where it's it's hilarious you
don't see that
i don't see the the comedic part of it i
do think it's it's cool
like i think it's cool i don't know if
it's like ha ha you're so i'm sure
amazon's like
i don't believe you that's hilarious you
know that's funny you i don't understand
you you think that's you're doing that
because it's funny
i think it's impressive like when people
come to multiple shows i think that's
impressive i'm like whoa that's
impressive you've come to multiple tour
stops like
that's cool i'm going to hire someone
this kid who is danielle well shout out
danny press he's come to every single
one of my shows
next to her i'm going to hire him to
come like be my assistant on tour like
don't understand what you're talking
about we're talking about adam sandler's
clothes and you saw him
but he should see that i have like
persistence right oh you think adam's
going to notice you
no no i want to go oh oh my god oh i
don't want to say it
something embarrassing did happen with
amazon i can't say it because it has
like
his like location but i mentioned
something on the show and it's something
that like
i don't know what to say say it and then
we'll edit it out maybe edit it out but
when i was talking about
a certain synagogue everyone's like oh
adam sandler goes and i swear i didn't
know and i felt really crazy
no i still go ahead you don't have to
say the synagogue name but what happened
no so i mentioned something on the show
once and i don't even know if it's true
but everyone's like oh she's doing that
because and i swear i didn't because i
don't want to be creepy like i love
being a fan
there's nothing creepy about buying all
this wardrobes and wearing them you
don't think i'm trying to smell it i
smell my clothes on poshmark i think
it's fine right for real you're not
being stupid no it's not creepy and
weird at all to buy his clothes for a
thousand dollars and smell it and wear
it
that's why i always also show moses
because the other thing is people think
i'm like trying to like
get with him and i'm like no like i have
a fiancee so moses and all my auntie
sandler video so he knows like hey i'm a
fiance who's israeli
because he did the zohan movie about
israelis you know he did so i was just
like hey there's a fiance i'm not trying
to get with you because everyone just
automatically assumes i want to sleep
with everybody that's not the case
you're me you're you're monogamous
you're in a happy relationship i just
think you want to smell it
same sandler buy this diamond probably
easily
easily he could yeah but would he
probably not
we
actually he's full jewish so are how
many so how many adam sandler outfits is
enough when it when do you have enough
well they're running out of them so hey
oh can i make it so now but what's funny
is they're buying all of them and now
people are making
fake ones and scamming you and making
thousands of dollars literally just
they put it up just knowing that you're
gonna buy it that's awesome
in fact i think we should try to
secretly scam trisha
oh it's not it's not hard i would like
if something goes up on adam wouldn't
that be awesome if i came
and was like does this look familiar i
sold it to you for a thousand dollars
i do get scammed sometimes i bought an
adam sandler outfit that he never even
wore it was from jack and jill we
watched the whole movie he didn't wear
it once it was a yamaka
and an applesauce shirt and he never
once wore it so why would you buy
something that you
does not even hold any reverence in your
heart like you haven't seen them
in the film i thought i saw that one
because i love jack and jill for real
people are really out here scamming you
like people are just making money off
you
girl you guys if you guys want any money
making ideas
go put out of sandler clothes if anyone
has adam sandler's outfits i'll buy them
but how can they certify it
i don't know exactly i don't want to
creep him out
it's too late but he said it's not
creepy i was being sarcastic someone's
like oh she's trying to get adam sandler
in front of me i'm like
i don't think he's gonna come on here oh
he will really yeah easy because you're
jewish
yeah say something in hebrew to him
is that romantic it's not romantic right
oh okay i don't mean it romantically i
don't know hebrew that well that's i
only say it to my fiancee who's
who's jewish and from israel you want to
talk about bracelet you want to talk
about adam sandler
and all the whole episodes saying that
he's an israeli jewish person that's not
a flex i mean it's just something
it's just a fact of his jewish people
are like
so enthralled with israeli jewish people
they're like wow you're from the land
it's very cool bro you got issues
but that's fine that's why we love you
okay let's talk about bryce hall this
little scumbag don't want his clothes
don't get me anywhere near his clothes
all right so bryce hall is someone who
got famous on tick tock
and he's like jake paul was back in the
day i feel like you know what i mean
that's the best he's worth i think he's
worse
because he's like he's such a little
douche
yeah he's definitely due to the month
yeah let's watch this
here is this a real thing no this is due
to the month we'll do it every month
don't shut the [ __ ] up
you have a hickey on your neck as we're
calling you a [ __ ] like shut up picky
on your neck
and then say don't [ __ ] slut-shame me
i'm
i know what the context of this is but
it's definitely small dick energy tiny
pee pee energy
sure also he's like five five i think so
yeah this dick is probably wrong for
sure a little man complex for sure
nothing wrong with short guys if you
haven't
okay i'm gonna tell you why you have no
point
as you guys have seen like videos or
maybe
heard from like what should daniel like
brendan taylor like
everybody okay so this is the other
story he peed off a balcony onto his
fans like
i'm sorry where at playlist live
so he like loved they loved it or what
playlist live
their their main insult was at least i
don't pee off of
playlist balconies or something i'm
going to explain the night
right now right really quick i'm going
to go ahead it was like
4 00 am you know i drink some apple
juice
and i i don't know this dude how is
there so many cuts
like i've he's already cut his video
like a hundred times he can't speak up
for it can you just
literally talk for five seconds without
cutting yeah i
drank a bunch of apple juice and then i
i can only imagine what happens in
between those cuts where it's like
oh and i was at playlist live i don't
wish it's on him but guaranteed to end
up in prison in the next five years for
sure
you think so that's prison not just jail
prison for sure i know kids like this
that i went to school with they're
like uneducated dumb asses but you get
some money whatever he'll be in prison
for sure
and i don't think about any other
influence i can't imagine any other
influencer being in prison he for sure
will be in five years what's the above
under on that
100 100 000. and people were
daring me like the people that i was
with bad influences by the way they were
daring me to
to pee off the balcony and you know he
didn't a lot of apples
oh is that like a euphemism for beer i
think he's saying i was drinking alcohol
probably because he's not 21. so he's
saying i was drinking
apple juice it's like okay how much
apple juice are you drinking
dude you're drinking beer and people
dared you to be off the balcony
i think i might hate bryce hall more
than jax films
[Music]
fantastic we love that new enemy
i yeah i have a dislike for him his
videos
i hate his videos oh my god we're not
here to shoot on jack's film let's stick
to the [ __ ] douche
enemy number one is now bryce hall for
the pink side who's enemy number one on
the black side
enemy number one obviously david dobrik
okay i changed my pink side to david
dobrik too yeah okay because
okay well let's finish watching the case
about bryce hall maybe he'll be the new
enemy number one
yeah i don't like him on people i don't
like that no that was bad and also
i drank apple juice and somebody dared
me to pee up the balcony so that's what
happened i don't know why y'all
overacting okay in the right and i just
was like hey there's a balcony right
there to my left everyone's like do it
you won't
and then i kind of did it with my dumb
ass but it was
and there was a lot of people with like
a whole bunch of different stories
saying like i actually peed on fans okay
so let's
let's just cut it straight you did it
and a story go to jail
you're [ __ ] degenerate bro i'll be in
prison soon also
this is the same one that said ariana
grande was using him for clout
so the intelligence is already like low
you're literally a tick tock star
4 am everyone was asleep it was just
stupid of me to do in general playlist
i'm super sorry by the way
still banned by the way here today we're
gonna be uh going to the clubhouse
but with a catch okay so this one is him
confronting another creator for talking
about him
tough guy five five tough guy [ __ ]
question telepathy
he's talking [ __ ] about me on the
internet so today i want to confront a
[ __ ] can i just walk through the
backyard
don't hit him i'm not going through it
okay that kid would follow him and hit
somebody you'll see a wild [ __ ] in his
natural habitat look there's smart you
in his exactly
nothing happened did you just intrude on
his back
[ __ ] thank you my god what's this
why is he in his backyard isn't that
like like
i think this is like a setup like the
clubhouse is like a tick-tock house
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're usually supposed to
back it up in person big shocker guys
there's another [ __ ] on the internet
dude you're a vlogger i'm talk [ __ ] you
come confront me a little bit seriously
tampon you're gonna cry you just went
for no you talk [ __ ] for no reason i
mean you went
you went off without your reason for no
reason like you're gonna talk about bro
code
like buddy beat his own best friend and
send him to the hospital this is me just
kidding
i don't know what anybody's talking
about but i could tell he's a dude he's
calling girls
bro the bro code it said his bro to the
hospital
i i don't know you guys are all
douchebags
bryce ain't sent [ __ ] to the law
maybe don't be a [ __ ] in person like
this because actually
got this for you yeah we already saw it
thumbnail real quick
stop it stop it that's all i wanted to
do i'm actually taking this [ __ ] cat
dude you're gonna return [ __ ] i'll see
you you'll see me do what actually my
friends see you please
oh your friends will see me why don't
you see me right now
no this is real i think
oh because you know you'll get your ass
[ __ ] what no because he's not
at least you admit it i hope your
friends do more than what you did here
and just sat here i was expecting like
something a little bit more interesting
that's the end of the video guys
everyone on the internet's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
peace out guys thank you guys [ __ ]
disconnect youtube
yo i love how he took the cat for he's
like actually i'm going to return this
this was like 20 bucks is that what he
said
he took the cat food he's like i'm gonna
take this it's like why wouldn't you
just leave him the cat food that's a
bigger disc
that he has to do something with the cat
food and then you know he's not gonna do
something with it and then someone's
gonna be like dude you gotta do
something with the cat food it's like
humiliating he's gotta deal with it but
bryce took it
because he actually wanted the twenty
dollars back wait why was the cat food
even there
because he was calling him a [ __ ] oh my
god
yeah he brought him a whole bag of cat
food this is embarrassing
on so many levels okay so he's dating
addison ray
who has like she's starring in like a
movie that she's all that remake like
she has like brand deals with raising
canes like
isn't she like embarrassed where's her
parents like this is so embarrassing i
would be
so embarrassing this is more normal
you think i'm gonna say this is more
embarrassing than emilio parents i think
that really appearance are more
embarrassing than this because this
kid's like what he's 19 but he looks
like he hasn't hit puberty yet like i
don't get these kids
how come they look like children they
are they
are right how old is bryce saw he has
he's like [ __ ] 19 i mean he is can't
even tr he's
out there talking about he drank apple
juice 21.
where in that video we are watching he's
21.
he's 21 he's a child he is literally no
but he looks like a literal 12 year old
what do you
love him woody allen would love that
dick
or maybe he's no michael jackson i guess
likes the boys strictly girls
because his own son you believe that
michael jackson stuff i thought you were
like a stan
i am totally anti-michael jackson but
you are yeah i think he did it for sure
i i know i'm i'm i mean like let's just
look at the fact
dude [ __ ] shares beds with little
kids case closed boom
case closed case closed you don't get in
bed with a little kid you don't
[ __ ] i went to his house i wasn't in
his bed yeah but you're not his type
first of all not even close at this
watch
bryce hall definitely douchebag of the
day
of the month to stop the large parties
held there
flagrant violation so this one is the
mayor had to intervene
because he was throwing these these uh
pandemic ragers what house is he in
is he in a house i think he's in the um
i think he's in the stack the snatch
house
the statutory house
i don't think that's a allegation
against him i'm just i don't know that's
what all these houses are the stat shows
we're in the snapchat spread who do you
think is more clout faze or him
phase probably has more clout so maybe
they should like
i feel like his face has been around oh
face phase as the organization has way
more club they're like
big deal more than bryce hall don't let
bryce hall hear you say that i caught
his breath he might catch those arms
who would women arm wrestle you were
brutal i mean he would probably win but
if he wants to come talk to me i'll talk
to him you know i mean he's like will
you talk [ __ ] about me i was like you
want to talk about why i'm talking [ __ ]
is cause you're a [ __ ] douchebag
i would love to hear what bryce hawks
say he's like i don't want to fight you
clearly but
if you want to talk about it dixie to
milo and start talking about us because
that's everything i love when little
tick tocker is like
this guy doesn't dare [ __ ] mention my
name dude don't even
compromise i'm like i'm like the uh
no people are definitely i'm the [ __ ]
boogeyman bro you mentioned my name
i think i'm more boogeyman than you oh
you're a boogeyman too that's what i'm
saying we're double trouble
my theory is like philip defranco
doesn't even talk about you anymore
because i'm associated with you and he's
like i think he's actually scared of me
for real
wait for good reason what does that mean
what good reason i don't think there's a
good reason he's scared i i think people
are scared of me because i think i'm
gonna
talk about them which you can't believe
i will yeah exactly
no no uh you know whatever
but i think people i think are people
are a little scared look i don't want to
be the person people are scared of
talking about and i also don't like the
fact that people think i'm always in
drama when i'm just saying truth
well it's true you are in drama always i
gotta pay the bills somehow
doesn't pay for itself on that lease all
right let's watch what's the
even the mayor's involved now the mayor
tweeted out
this is true bryce hall is a giant
douche the mayor everybody
okay and put our communities at risk
here's some footage from the party
this is bryce hall's party no mask
literally in a hearing for the mirror
he pretended to be la public building
safety officials started just going into
buildings and seeing what he could go
with which is a felony by the way
oh my god that's something he's gonna be
in prison he is gonna be involved in
this area
trying to get access to he is continuing
the long legacy of pranksters going to
jail for felonies we're with the los
angeles department
building we got some corporate
complaints about the kitchen safety
is that like a mcdonald's or something i
don't know
anyways yeah it's not it's not funny or
interesting really
that was actually too [ __ ] easy they
didn't even hesitate you didn't do
anything you really got them i got into
their i got to do the boy bathroom dude
that was too [ __ ] easy yo i washed my
hands inside the mcdonald's the
employees are at mcdonald's that was too
[ __ ] easy
nothing he got then he got to see where
they fried don't even give a [ __ ]
they're like whatever
yeah they're like okay dude you guys
always keeping this messy bag here
how long have these been in here they're
good for a year anonymous
customers saying that they got diarrhea
from the beans okay can we just inspect
the beans
to see if it's yeah sure they're braver
than i am
oh here he is getting in a fight which
he does apparently all the time
people they don't know fighting
like this is a deeply unloved person
saying like the parents of these
ticktackers need to like step in
like oh his parents have lost total
control
[Music]
like this is someone else recording him
candidly getting in a fight somewhere
like i'm sorry who doesn't
i don't feel sorry for him he's super
arrogant and like
i mean i do in like an indirect way of
like knowing he's just so uh
so damaged and and and uh insecure
this is the generation once again that
david dober phrase everyone wants to be
like little david doberg and they're
doing stupid [ __ ]
oh he takes steroids that explains
everything enhancement or
his recent youtube videos oh yeah you
know i don't blame you he's not really
wait what's this wait what's the story
with this
uh phase jarvis do you remember dan
something happened where they got in a
beef with this guy faith jarvis
no there's a bunch of phase people is it
not the one with the house with my
no okay that's faze banks he's one of
he's someone else but he's in his group
he's in phase wow okay so anyway he got
in this beef with this phase guy
and he made a video saying here's his
phone number
he literally just put his phone number
in a youtube video and then it got
bryce bryce put a video saying here's
face's phone number yes
and it got taken down by youtube
obviously but he literally that's like
the number one thing you can like be on
anything like twitter will let you do
anything but like if you dock someone
like you're kicked off all the platforms
he
made a youtube video it got hundreds of
thousands of views maybe millions of
views i don't know
before youtube took it down that's like
like the only thing that like
people care about like doxxing anything
else you could do but that's crazy
this number i was going to call him
confront him tell him how messed up and
immature that was because leaking bro
this guy's trying to confront people all
the time
and two it's immature it's [ __ ]
illegal why yeah
yeah he got a strike for this one hey
what
we didn't show it no it's the other guy
the other guy leaked his phone number
first or addison ray i think it was an
accident or something i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened but he put someone's
phone number on his youtube video
at least he's he's acknowledging and
taking accountability no he's talking
about what the other guy did
he's not taking compound ability he said
this guy did this so i'm going to show
his phone number
oh so he docks the jail yeah this guy
what happened to his faces he's like
i don't know he assaulted this guy
both
[Music]
i don't blame you he's not really that
relevant but he leaked addison's number
i was going to call him confront him
tell him how messed up and immature that
was
because leaking people's number one is
illegal it's called doxing and two it's
immature
so he did that he said what you did was
illegal immature and then he showed his
phone number
so he did it too yeah he did it too
obviously we're not gonna show it
people would have been on the right side
had me not done that i know
so you [ __ ] dude he [ __ ] you up wait
how do you know that's from him
i'm assuming that's that's what is it
this is zach oh assaulted his friend
zach clayton
i took a fat l last night he took an
hour we were both in the wrong
both were drunk and everything that
happened
wasn't just one person's fault i take
[ __ ] ownership of
of doing everything like i was
i was in the wrong for for touching you
guys at all
but nobody knows the real [ __ ] story
i can't even tell you
he was just saying i was trying to
[ __ ] which is basically just for
everything
you get
[Music]
because he knows that you cheated on
your girlfriend i'm just like this sucks
so tan is saying his friend said he
cheated on addison
and confronted him and then he beat him
up i don't know who can follow this [ __ ]
this trick quotes my tweet
and says if you cared so much about zach
why'd you [ __ ] me imagine responding to
someone's assault allegation by lying
and saying that you [ __ ] me and even
if you literally did
you still assaulted zach said lauren
we've known each other for a while
for this girl the media into thinking
that
i'm a cheating scumbag and now we need a
paparazzi that we can trust to make this
i hate this one this is the one we're to
troll the media first of all you're not
trolling you have to say you're a troll
second of all
he doesn't give a [ __ ] hollywood fix is
not the media it's a youtube channel
that forces collabs on people by shoving
cameras in their face with an iphone
when they're out
horses collabs on people that's funny no
this guy me and moses got on there
he literally for real yeah oh yeah this
guy with an iphone comes out and just is
like
an iphone bro come on step your [ __ ] up
what do you think about what's your
what's the thing with gabby hannah how
do you think about the front of his
podcast and we're like oh we asked you
about me
yeah we'll [ __ ] go
someone's paying this person to like
follow him with an iphone it was so
embarrassing i was like couldn't you
just stop at least get a real camera
yeah like make it look
kind of it was so it's so embarrassing
so bryce sets up this
pr he wants to prank the media into
thinking he's cheating on his girlfriend
he's gonna troll the media i love how he
goes i'm pranking everyone to think i'm
a cheating scumbag okay maybe it's not a
prank maybe everyone already thinks that
about you oh he's completely believable
do you trust kevin wong i trust him
what up kevin me and addison are about
to like break the internet
by doing a from breakfast
you think you can trust me the internet
is
not as unbroken we're about to break the
internet with this cheating scandal
i i bet if you have 100 people on the
street they would have no idea who bryce
all's dating or
how do you know who bryce hall is no how
do you know who bryce hall is no we're
about to break the internet
with one dude with the iphone this is
the problem with social media is like
the tech especially tick tock it's all
little kids that watch
talk so these people are thinking that
there's somebody like they're of
importance like it's cool you have a
following
all right we're about to go do it are
you excited for this i mean
no hi your boyfriend assaulted somebody
how your boyfriend pees on fans like
you're addison ray one of the biggest
influencers like why are you even
participating in this video
you don't know him you don't know him
her parents are awful too your parents
need to be in on this they're okay okay
okay
slow down slow down whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
all right all right all right all right
how about get addison away from me
you're shooting too wide right now
i'm gonna shoot my load everywhere oh
god that's all that's you're on the
wrong platform for that
i'm going to be the most hated person on
the internet
literally nobody cares okay this girl do
you know her no
she was like the charlie demilio of
musically before tic-tac was musically
this girl was like really the biggest
he's big on tick-tock she was and now
nobody cares
but that's what i'm saying they all go
into oblivion eventually
i mean they're pretty popular on youtube
though too for now
got it look at that super zoom about to
break the internet bruh prank's done
we're gonna do one more
by the way by the way when this went out
literally all i saw anyone saying was
that it's obviously fake
yeah no one was like oh my god broke the
[ __ ] internet dude
this is the first strategic chaotic
thing we've ever done everything it'll
be awesome
we [ __ ] up if he actually went home
and [ __ ] her
you know what i mean i don't know nobody
would ever ever
[ __ ] suspect this is why you need to
get rid of your tesla because yeah
this time
i'm not car shimming it's just bryce
hall which is crazy
[ __ ] these news outlets never trust what
you see on the internet
[Music]
by the way the conclusion he's making is
so stupid
never trust what you read on the
internet because you're going out and
and
holding hands with a girl like am i
supposed to not believe that you're
cheating
you're the only one that knows that dude
your conclusion is totally stunned not
pranks either like i don't get it what
is it
noah mainly dixie right it's dixie sorry
dixie
about this seriously so i have two
strippers coming over i'm gonna have
noah blindfolded
so this was one word dixie is dating
this guy noah back
there whatever and he brings two
strippers and blinds folds him and then
calls the girlfriend
calls his girlfriend and shows him what
the strippers but he doesn't know what's
happening
pretty [ __ ] up show her the strippers
get her reaction
then take the blindfold off of noah and
then see both of their reactions dixie's
probably going to be mad
bro i'm freaking out is she on no no
stop
[ __ ] wait does he really not know
what's going on though i
hope he does don't worry yo deadass
what the [ __ ] is what is going on
[Applause]
did she get mad she just hung up
immediately i said you were pranking him
oh okay well that was the prank i just
didn't want you to be mad at noah this
is all me
yeah check the footage i didn't even
look i swear to god
dixie didn't deserve that but everything
will be
it was okay so uh
do you find that acceptable i didn't see
it so you really can't comment on it
because uh
i saw it and i thought it was trash okay
mom nobody
okay mom nobody cares about you the
parents are so embarrassing my parents
are attached with the paparazzi
commenting on like a prank someone did
on me it's like so that's it that's it
i mean you know douchebag of the month
yay
let's go exercise i want to know who can
do a pull-up that's what i really care
about we will find bryce hall there
catch us at the place
oh he's looking for me catch us at the
pull-up bar [ __ ]
catch me at the monkey bars [ __ ] i'm
about to take your ass out listen i
don't want to fight anybody
i love he goes you don't want fun
because you're [ __ ] it's like not cause
i was loved by my parents
right if you want to have a conversation
we can do that um
bryce you want to call into the podcast
and talk things through let's do it
yeah i'm not so much a fighter but i'll
get down you would trash somebody though
like
i would not go toe-to-toe with you i
have so much aggression that's why
like there's a lot that i hold i i
you would [ __ ] kill me i would not
walk away live from a fight with you
yeah probs probs also you've seen [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'm just saying
that puts fight into somebody
yeah i've been seeing [ __ ] like you've
seen [ __ ] you know
yeah definitely okay i'm green what
i'm green that's what they say like
green
youthful amateur not youthful but like
i'm not i'm not i've been not been
through [ __ ] i don't like the dick from
five dollars man
you never got a candlestick jump up of
your ass i don't think forcibly
that's putting [ __ ] grit in your
spirit totally does
i have ptsd like i sometimes wake up
like i'm saying i don't want to fight
someone with ptsd
i for sure have psd for sure that gives
you extra energy
when you're in a fight i get freaked out
yeah
the p stands for powerful
especially when i like black out it's
just like watch out yeah
anyway you want to do thanks for not
triggering me
for like the whole year so far 2021 has
been a year of non-triggers i think
we're just
we trust each other or i think well i i
think you trust me more
people think you just have handled me
better like watch ethan's really knows
how to handle trish she knows when she's
about to disassociate and steer
i don't know if he's that good in that
well we haven't had like a bit i
i i hope that i can if it happens again
but we haven't had like a big moment
since the last one
i think we just had a good i think we
just have a good understanding i miss dr
drew though
you just want to [ __ ] dr drew like i
literally don't need him
no maybe he could help us with our
eating disorders
dr drew with peace and love he literally
just gonna be like ethan you're fat
what's wrong with you trisha you're a
goddess
he's like trisha you're a goddess you're
fine ethan you're fat and you're weak
that's why you can't lose weight
that's what he did last time he did that
he was like trisha you're amazing ethan
you're a loser
i was like okay dr joe nice thank you
nice couples there
i think he's a professional i give an
unbiased opinion
[Music]
i don't like him i mean i like him but
not but i don't need him come out you
know
i like doctor jo cut that reverse it
retake it and play it over with this
i like dr jim can you do that thank you
don't cut it keep that in that's funny
yeah i didn't mean it though i didn't
mean it with peace i love dr joe
can we put in our frenemies hoodie with
peace and love like in the heart where
the heart oh that's a really good idea
is it hard to do i don't know no we
could do anything study fresh we could
do anything i know that's like more
you're saying but i think it's becoming
the h3
empire saying you say it here peace and
you know what it's from
it's from ringo starr cancelled we're
anti-beetles on the pink side
no but you have to see this video he he
puts out a video because he gets a ton
of fan mail
and he goes i am warning you to all my
dear fans if i get
any mail past may 1st i will be throwing
it in the garbage with peace and love
he goes with peace and love with peace
and love anything that comes after may
1st will be
thrown in the dumpster iconic that's
right here i'll pull it up
one of my favorite things it's one of my
favorite um
one of my favorite videos because it's
like i love the peace and love combined
with the i'm throwing it away i'm
warning you with peace and love
oh yeah here that's me if you see me and
you come for in for a hug with peace and
love i will run away i do not want to
hug during covet season which
also it's like directed all artsy it's
crazy video and that's awesome ringo
starr is crazy though
is he doing a living beetle no paul
mccartney's alive what's wrong with you
oh don't ask me if he would probably
forget which one he is
well first of all you can't be you can't
hate the beatles and not know who paul
mccartney is that just means you don't
know enough about the beatles
okay no more about the beatles than you
we already proved this in our trivia
thing anyway you don't even
the original drummer just because you
know this exactly i don't even like the
beatles and i can tell you the original
drummer
i just didn't know which one was
comfortable i know one of them is one
guardian it doesn't know which what is
this what the heck
yeah exactly it starts off really close
to his face for no reason i think he's
older in this
yeah it's recent just happened this is a
serious message
to everybody watching my update right
now
peace and love peace and love i love it
i want to tell you please
after the 20th of october do not send
fan mail to any address that you have
nothing will be signed after the 20th of
october
if that has a date on the envelope it's
going to be tossed
i'm warning you with peace of mind i am
warning you so no more fan mail thank
you
thank you and no objects to be signed
nothing
uh anyway peace love peace and love i am
warning you with peace and love
nothing nothing i love that he was still
signing autographs like
i know that's pretty good that's pretty
gangster i mean that's really nice
dude how could the evils are like the
best people like do you think he'd come
on the podcast
oh for sure was that paula ringo that
was ringo do you think gringo would come
definitely paul mccartney definitely
which one has a higher chance of coming
for real be real paul mccartney he's an
easy pull ringo's a little
i think we could get them both which
ones tell me for real i know you're
being kind of stupid
both of them are impossible but which
one has a higher chance bringo ringo
because he's
because he's the lesser paul mccartney
is like the most famous player here
in this neighborhood in the gate of
community would you meet oh you met him
with your
with your peeps yeah that's awesome oh
okay i love ringo
has more connections than anyone you
think you come to our wedding if we
bring those
if you want to come to our wedding open
invitation with peace and love
and adam sandler oh
i am i am inviting you with peace and
love
rsvp by october 20th or your
invitation is going in the bin most
money i could pay adam sandler to come
to the wedding is maybe
half a million but he probably doesn't i
don't think he does appearances you pay
them half a mil i people have a million
to come be in our wedding photos
jesus i'm glad he's not coming that's
too much money um did you all right
let's wrap it up let's wrap it up for
his daughter's bar mitzvah he got adam
levine to play it
i re i saw that on howard seems a little
bougie like okay
rich people like well he's so rich i
know but it just feels a little like
dance for me monkey
it's like come over here and play for my
daughter how much money for adam sandler
to be danced with
i know but it's like this guy is a world
famous musician
come do one show for my daughter's bar
mitzvah which by the way it's like a bot
mitzvah it's not that serious you know
maybe it feels like it at the time but
it's like
i'm sure i'm sure but still your next
daughter that has one mitzvah i'll come
perform
for free didn't ask don't have a
daughter either
no adam sandler's other uh okay yeah it
could have happened they might be
fancy also don't say that for 500 000
we'll come perform at your bar mitzvah
anybody who wants us out there
i'm not sure i would does it include
travel does it include travel
do i have to stay there like give me the
details i do it for half a million i'll
stay with you but i have to share the
money with you
i'll come on your birth right is it half
a million each or 250 a piece
250 a piece that's not as much money
you wouldn't show up to apartments i
might say no
i'll do it look i i don't i don't i
don't need 250 000 with peace and love
i'll do it for sure because it's so
awkward you're going to be there and you
have to be super nice like
oh tell me what's your torah portion
what does it mean to you all this dumb
[ __ ] like this i don't [ __ ] care hey
hire me i speak hebrew
also like why is this rich kid entitled
to this like
extraordinary experience not that but
like not with me but like anyone like
why because they're so rich they're
entitled to this extraordinary cool it
is cool
but like it's like you don't deserve
that just because you have money
you know what i mean like everybody i
know but like you don't have to give it
to me that doesn't mean they're gonna
turn out great i mean there's a ton of
no but i'm saying
you don't i feel like you don't have to
give it to him you know what i mean it's
like
you are [ __ ] just a dude the fact
that you can pay me to come dance for
you at your bar mitzvah is [ __ ]
poor middle class rich i would say
middle class okay so when you're
under middle class i grew up under
middle class like i would love like we
always had this debate too about like
chores and stuff like that like i would
love to give my kids the experience i
didn't have i would love to buy them
like
like toys that i didn't have and stuff
that's different than having like
[ __ ]
uh adam levine come do a private show
having a
uh someone you know what i'm saying like
that's a different style yeah maybe
they're super they go to hebrew school
they have a tough life
but for good and bad will be there for
you adam sandler and any other jewish
person that wants us at their bar
mitzvah
adam sandler 500 thousand table all you
have to do is show up and take a picture
not me you can't buy me i'm not a
[ __ ] monkey i don't come dan
tap dance for you at your bat mitzvah
you're just a normal girl dude just
enjoy your [ __ ] bad mitzvah
have a cake have your family over eat
some hors d'oeuvres get a little drunk
on man of chevits like you do
i'm not coming because i don't know you
and i don't give a [ __ ] about you and
you can't pay me 250 thousand dollars to
pretend like i give a [ __ ] about your
bad mitzvah sounds like someone had a
bad moments about what happened
embarrassed you she cooked bad food what
was it no i had a good bar mitzvah oh
really no i just have a
i don't like when people do that did you
fall off the chair
and so you're traumatized no my bar
mitzvah was great oh really
yes well adam sandler wasn't your dad so
i can't be that great
only people with adam sandler is the dad
i'm sure she had a battery wait did i
trigger you
oh yeah i'm disappointed i feel like
you're angry i'm so angry
you don't know her no i'm not saying
anything bad about the girl i think she
could be here
it's more common towards people who i
bet she's humble
no i agree out of the limelight she's
not you're doing a great job oh she's
the queen
she's a little sandler yes i agree i'm
not lucky too
yes she have the mom credit she's
amazing i give her mom credit
yeah the mom gets credit there's a
little girl hollywood relationship
that's stable
girls i don't mean to deserve adam yes
and britney spears at your wedding
you're right you're right do you think
steven would come to my wedding
i don't think he gets many appearance
requests he was in the wedding singer
remember he's like why didn't singer oh
yeah you could get buschemie he could
sing at the wedding he's saying at the
moment how much you paid
me um oh you paid two he wasn't mr deeds
big daddy wedding singer
he might be able to game for less can we
put that out there
10k for me he has to sing adam smarter
says to show up
sebastian needs to sing like he does
adam sandler do you really want to
hurt me you can have steve buscemi uh
show up for 150 000. wait what
[Music]
that's so funny he's just schmoozing
stupid
you paid him on 150 thousand there he
hasn't what is anyone else on there dan
is adam sandler on there
there's no way adam sandler has a
billion dollar contract with netflix
not on this this is like the camera go
ahead dan go ahead adam sandler's
uh appearance fee is seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
can you chip in 250 me yeah i'm not
paying for that
come on right off all right
gift yeah what the [ __ ] am i you're i'm
not your financer
call your financer i know her email now
i'll call her hi
hi we need uh 250 for adam sandler at my
friend's wedding
staff friends sister we share the same
mother-in-law like she's in love yeah
we're sister we're in-laws
sister-in-law are you is that a real
sight that can't be
there is no way adam sanders is going to
show i mean
obviously i think he's passing on a lot
of this stuff probably it's not like
you get an offer gosh i don't know
he didn't come to someone's wedding if
you type in adam sandler wedding crasher
he like shows up to people's weddings so
maybe we'll just throw up he's on the
side
okay maybe is on there i'm curious who
else is on that site
uh let's see i mean who who do you want
jeff dunham what
jeff tim dillon tim dillon why tim
dillon
jeff dunham is on here how much uh half
a milli
yeah he just he should be he's pretty
popular but i wanted that [ __ ] i
wouldn't i would pay not to have james
keep your [ __ ] puppets away from my
wife oh he's puppet or blue collar we
blue collar comedy tour
he's the puppet boy he's the racist
puppet guy
how is he getting happy there's no way
that's real no he's really popular he's
famous
larry you can get larry for just 150.
chevy's 150 and he is in movies with
adam's handler all right can we stop
this charade let's go do something
right there so let's go do some pull-ups
what do you think all right let's do it
let's settle this beef once and for all
hey guys we are out here at balboa park
getting ready for our fitness
competition so excited
trisha do you still believe you can do a
single pull-up
i have confidence this week i do it yes
really
yeah you're feeling like on a scale of
one to ten how confident are you feeling
i always have it
at nine and a half dude there's no way
this whole thing got started because
trish just said she can do a pull-up and
i said there's no
[ __ ] way you can do a poke my
confidence that i can do a single
pull-up is more like an
eight so you have more yeah no for sure
can do at least one
well the first competition is who has
the fatter ass
so i put on the these tick tock meme
leggings
you're kind of cheating with your jock
strap holding your ass up
no where's the struck strap strap okay
underneath your butt
oh for real yeah okay here okay how do
you
accentuate your ass how do girls do that
well you have to kind of push it out and
then like the camera angle has to get a
little lower
come get in get in that [ __ ] man no push
out more
you got to put it before yeah because
the pants is yeah
it's so small that it's like this feels
wrong
am i doing it right dan
maybe like squat it oh squat it pull
your chest forward and your butt back
chest forward my ass crack is out
i'm wearing a cup for uh
nobody needs to see my junk last time we
did this you can see everything and i
don't need that is it padded no it's not
it's
empty oh okay it's supposed to go inside
yikes okay all right let's just get
right to it shall we i'm ready
so before we get too much into the
exercising
we are going to stretch obviously like
every good athlete does is this part of
the competition like does someone win if
they can hold their toes longer
everything's part of the conversation
okay
what do we win pizza keto pizza i have
broccoli pizza in my freezer
you want that as your prize we can well
whoever
wins gets the extra slice i need you to
start losing weight so it motivates me
to start losing weight because i look so
fat next to you then i'm going to start
losing weight too
so you need to start it oh you want me
to like shame you
yeah and to i'm i'm doing my best i
think that shaming works
not for me but i do think it works for
people but see i'm
are you saying that me just losing
weight is fat shaming you or do you want
me to fat shame
no the commons will fascinate me yeah
ethan's looking great you're just a
little pig when
we were chefs they're like wow well they
look so much bigger standing
yeah i did look massive i remember that
i was like
it's fun we should just rename it to
fatty's eating pork or some [ __ ] two
big fat porky fat [ __ ] well you're not
fat anymore you lost upon a nap
not bad anymore i lost two pounds so
we're gonna be grabbing our toes and
seeing how long we can
hold it okay okay now can you even grab
your toes
i mean my knees aren't oh that's pretty
good damn girl you should make a only
fans
thanks i have one only twitch.com
i'm my form isn't perfect i'll i'll
definitely
concede that yeah you're an easy i i
told you i'm not easier it's not good
form i i said that
okay that's not the stretch if you're
not knees aren't down i mean if my knees
are all right
we're inclined we're stressed
not everything's accomplished i use that
everything is competition rewind the
tape
okay planks all right planks three two
one thank you okay i can do it oh you
can do it too
oh [ __ ] this is okay you can't hold that
look at you look at you you're the one
shaking
and i have you feel all that weight what
weight
all that weight i'm weightless no you're
not
you are so [ __ ] you can't do is this
the voice
how are you holding it so long i'm good
i have good core strength i'm not even
gonna do this why are you so good at
this
put that leg down what the [ __ ] is this
trish is an elite athlete gotta be on
top more
oh interesting you hold yourself up
because you don't want to have all your
fatty weight on top of your partner
so you gotta hold yourself i feel like
when you're on top you're one of those
guys that put all their weight down like
this for sure
i think they'll put it on me either says
uh oh she probably gets crushed
she complains that that i hurt her back
once
every one time i was like oh god because
you put too much weight on her
that's why i try not to be on top that's
why we do it from the side
from the back because i want her to
survive having sex with me
has she ever smashed you moses during
sex no
i don't buy it i hold myself up so good
you saw those core that planks
i was impressed thank you let's see
let's see how long you can go
you want to time it i'm just impressed i
i i okay
you want to try again or you're just
going to watch me i'm here to i'm just
here to comment most you want to put a
timer on like a minute see if i can hold
it for a minute
if you hold it for a minute i will buy a
rolls royce for yourself
i know it's rewarding to myself but
you're the one that wants me to get it
we'll be matching that's what i'm saying
i don't think you can do it no way
how are you doing good i mean you feel
like you're gonna make it
i am so shocked i am
so freaking impressed by trisha right
now i will go
[ __ ] waste all my money on a rolls
royce don't make me laugh
holy [ __ ] i got a rolls royce not a
match
so you're okay with me getting the
rolls-royce for the show
she says she's her hands are tied yes
she can't say no
okay okay all right here we go
ready down
i lost is that a win is that w i wasn't
even going down as well anyways my boobs
hurt
why do your boobs sir what is it i don't
know i think i need new implants
it's been six years do they go sour or
something yeah you can feel them
whirling around you get them out and
then put new ones in
i've had two boob jobs but does that
boob technology work
improve so like maybe it feels more
natural or do you like the fake look
i like the fake i wanted to be faker but
mine are too big faker
with the roundness on top that'll be my
gift
to me
slow down girl
oh you saw that what are you doing dude
i'm on 14
14
i can't complete with this
yeah i'm blown away i don't know what
where this
where this extreme athleticism is coming
from it's
crazy how extreme no i'm i i'm
i'm honestly you're out of my league
right now okay so
balance you're in my [ __ ] space
you're in my space
get the [ __ ] out of my personal space if
you're gonna be doing a balancing
competition you have pretty good um
balance actually
[Music]
don't knock me over wait i was goofing
hold on i'm gonna do it again i don't
want to lose you
i'd rather die i'm not [ __ ] around
i'm trying to get
[Music]
this is not tranquility bruh [ __ ] this
you're gonna fall
you're so unstable look at you wobbling
what i didn't touch
no even oh my god okay so i beat you the
first time you've been second now okay
three it's out of three oh [ __ ] okay
[Music]
you see that shadow of the plane that
was epic
i'm tired i did 25 sit-ups
that was pretty good i feel you are all
severely underestimating
my basketball skills oh
dan your height man
i feel like i don't even need to you got
to make the basket
oh wow lame hit the rim i mean lame
i got it it's like course
oh that was a [ __ ] brick
i get to defend you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
one-handed oh i don't think that's the
right technique watch this layup i'm
gonna make it
[Music]
i made it okay i think that's a dub for
me right competition should be how many
you can make in a minute
what this ain't [ __ ] we're not
playing for tokens if you could take the
ball for me
that's not fair i'm not coordinated
get out of here you lose i do not i
can't do this you guys
you can i can't run anymore
i'm gonna be out here all day so who's
the longest who holds the longest let's
make the rules clear this time you're
gonna win everything i'm not gonna bet
against you in there i didn't win a
basketball player
yeah well basketball i shred i have the
ghost of kobe you didn't check it
oh my god that's blasphemy okay ready
yeah okay go
it was like my strange addiction that
girl was addicted to being pregnant are
you breaking already
no are you yeah this is very hard for me
i'm good you are good yeah what how are
you good
i've got the size of a horse i feel like
i'm doing more though
than you yeah okay i'm out
you keep going because you're you're
just so honestly i would never bet
against you again
really keep going i'm the winning
client's deal
i got horse legs that's why there's seed
under you that's
stupid so we're debunking the myth that
fat people are unhealthy
i didn't say you were healthy let's get
that straight no i'm in dirt
what is it endurance i have endurance i
can have sex for like an hour i have
endurance
it's squatting on the dick like is that
yeah so if you're bouncing like this
that's like
squat size and then you pulsate up okay
come on this
all my fans
you're [ __ ] up you can't huh
this is so pathetic i'm so bad at it i'm
so
tired already trisha just messed up
already
are you tired no i'm out
i'm burning i'm in pain okay let's do
trick jumping
okay but i won the jump rope this is the
true winner
that's not the competition it is now
[Music]
i can't believe you hop in the middle ah
okay we're done i win
you literally didn't win that
[Music]
yes run like the wind
i didn't even lift off did i 649.
world record it went up it did yeah
okay not to flex but i need this like
really tight
oh my god i'm so dude somebody's got to
get a shot of this
look at how [ __ ] huge i am it's not
even
that was tight on me too but we do weigh
the same which is interesting i mean i
do think i'm heavier than we should
weigh ourselves when we get home i think
i'm way heavier than you
well i mean you've got like [ __ ] tits
[Music]
got it got it put your arms down
get your hands off your food
how'd we do okay my mile was 45 minutes
not joking that's like slower than
walking
yeah i had the record did you crawl you
had the record for the longest mile i
swear and illinois had the longest
prestigious
uh award i feel like a pig literally
getting the trough
okay here i go i'm not confident right
now with my once my hands on the bars
i'm not feeling good
i'm nervous that was good
no i didn't do it i didn't get close oh
that's not considered one
how is that considered one i didn't even
get you have to get your chin over the
bar
chin up i thought you just had to be up
a little i'm gonna crush this [ __ ]
pants
are you being serious i did [ __ ] say
i've gained like 100 pounds since the
last time i did 100 pounds of muscle
this is like 100 pounds of [ __ ] glue
to my gut right now
i'm going arms are shot you guys this is
embarrassing that's not how i wanted
this to go
i'm nervous now okay i'm just gonna jump
as high as i can try a squat and go okay
wow this is pathetic
i need a running start well then sure
okay you need you need a jet pack
no i'm maybe i'll do it it's just the
sun's in my face i think you think
that's affecting the strength of you
i literally can't see
[ __ ] what was that ready okay this is
all you
i got it more never mind
yeah i guess i caught some movement yeah
i gotta fight
well i didn't realize trisha thought
that was a pull-up
no we had to do something called the
flex arm hang and this is it right
listen what you just said how long can
we hang for should we try that yeah
okay that sounds more in our league
ready
oh my god i'm so fat
[Music]
this is the big tiebreaker and to be
honest i don't know that i can take you
because
you've proven you're you're a goliath
you're a warrior princess you're xena oh
thank you
thank you are you feeling confident that
you could beat me right now
yeah do you feel like you're zena you
are xena i don't know what that is do
you know the warrior princess
no i don't know that like under the
giant maybe oh my god i could your grip
is already scaring me
and you've got like this crazy and your
hand is all crazy that's like spray tan
like you've squeezed the life out of
someone's neck before
oh my god you're going to demolish me
you've got baby hands dude i could tell
by your grip you're going to crush
i know i'm like sweating sorry you were
going to kill me dude i could feel your
strength coursing through your arms i'm
scared of my nails okay
you say went down three two one oh yeah
she's strong
she's strong boy she's powerful
but you've got oh my god she is so
strong stop
hear me get rest don't break it
she's so strong where'd you get this
drink
this girl has been through [ __ ] in life
i could tell she has seen things
she has seen you're making me laugh oh
my god she is so powerful i'm not
[ __ ] right you're scaring me
[Applause]
oh thank god i thought you were gonna
win i wasn't playing that up
i thought you were gonna dunk i don't
think it was fair because you were like
flipping your wrist
like as about so i would have broken it
oh no it's not a technique are you
allowed to do that
whoa exactly it's your turn
it's red you wanna do left hand i mean
okay i feel like i have a stronger left
hamstring i think i'm a really weak one
okay ready
okay no bending the wrist okay okay
three two one
oh she's so strong i swear to god you're
bending your wrist on me i'm not bending
it okay you're pulling my arm towards
you
it's just not fair what you're doing to
me and why are you so strong you're like
whole culture female version
this is crazy what is this amazonian
strength
oh thank goodness making me laugh it's
not fair i can't focus dude you're too
strong
i can't deal with it whatever all right
that means i win i mean you technically
didn't because i won more competitions
than you but if this is what makes you
want to win fine
yeah but the jump roping i definitely
won
i think look we agreed that this was it
so i think
ethan you could play the slide
everything the balloons
fine ethan's the winner ethan wins
next week we should do torbjorn so i win
again like jewish trivia
famous jewish trivia yeah okay okay
let's go get the rolls-royce and then
get fast food
with our rolls-royce which is the whole
vibe
how is it
me too i feel like
it's definitely the cleanest ride ever
but it's kind of embarrassing just to be
in a little bit
right it's the opposite of embarrassing
it's more embarrassing if your heart
breaks down no it's so show off you
that's why
but yours is more understated you bought
me internet that was so nice
you're welcome you just got a
rolls-royce so i was like you're so nice
the lady in front she goes she doesn't
say anything you don't explain she just
goes trish about your food
like we all know trisha all right
because you could have been just like
you know they do that trend
she goes trisha bought you food i was
like okay is that all you said is okay
she said trisha bought you food well i
was like wow okay
you know what i do that anyways for
people behind me all the time you do
yeah it's a thing it's a trend people do
and then they usually do that we
shouldn't do that
and then you pay and then usually they
pay for the people behind them like it's
like a training
well someone eventually stops it you
know what man she told me them
i said i want to pay for his food she
goes okay but it's 6 24.
okay like it's so small i don't couple
anyways it was a celebratory dinner
does it taste better in a rolls royce
that
definitely
people asked for our autographs we were
like popping we were blowing this in and
out
dwight we all know who we were oh yeah
i've given so many autographs
maybe they're not allowed to ask for a
picture maybe that's why they do the
autographing
what do you write when someone asks for
autograph in their name
just their name and then love i said
love you girl
love you girl do you love her you do
love it
i don't know what's right i appreciate
you did you
ethan and then i wrote ethan klein like
i wrote my last name that doesn't seem
i should play age three you think age
three
did you put your last name mm-hmm oh you
do whatever should be this
right if i saw you could drive through
i'd be like where is he uh oh there's
someone who's next to us
it's okay okay
i get so paranoid um
we should just do our podcast like this
this is so much fun this is a new pod
that was a great ride i loved it see no
regrets i hope you don't like wake up
so far where the [ __ ] are we going so
far no you're close to you it's very
nice
is that what the is that we put in my
navigation
something's weird oh the closest one was
ucla or sunset
and this was closest to your house
i'm so good i got a little milkshake
keto tomorrow
yeah tomorrow when we start going are
you really yeah for real thousand
percent because like you're gonna lose
weight and i'm gonna be like okay i need
to like catch up
mm-hmm cause babes swear i swear we
talked about this we're making
hard-boiled eggs for life
what are you going to do to help her i
love keto oh really
yeah just give me eggs chicken meat
yeah can you get down with this yeah
yeah i like keto things so i'm this is
like my last meal yeah don't be smart
though because you asked me if like
fruit is bitter
which is nice you have to be you have to
be i think i'm gonna be pretty strict
though like
eggs chicken like i think i'm gonna be
like as strict as i can be i don't think
i'm gonna do like the cheese and stuff
why cheese is keto well cheese breaks my
skin out
tomorrow i'm gonna have like like my
skin's been clearing up because i've not
been eating cheese
yeah i could eat three of these oh i
have one
no i was saying i could why are you
trying to make me fat
no vegan you can eat whatever you want
can we heat up
why you got one in your bag it has a bun
on it but i can give you the patty
no i'm not gonna rub it i'm good why i
don't need it
what did you got an extra burger yeah
mm-hmm how many burgers did you get
i got one but i had a chicken sandwich
mcdonald's we had a falafel truck
falafel
and i had these cheese fries and i'm
full do you want to forreal patty
no i don't want to take your meal
i'm not going to eat it like i really am
you're really not going to eat it i
swear to give me the [ __ ] food
if you're just going to throw it out the
cheese literally were so
filling oh yeah don't eat the bun though
you don't have to tell me oh what the
[ __ ] excuse me what the [ __ ] did you
just hand me
that's how she is just meat and bread
yeah but i swear i'm not gonna eat it i
promise you on everything i won't eat it
everywhere that's all she eats you smell
this meat
just eat the meat
okay i'm gonna be so skinny next week
when you see me
if i do this for real obviously i'm
gonna rolls-royce eating a [ __ ] like
this is the most unbelievable right here
i know it does suck when you have money
to like afford food but you can't eat
the food because you're fat
like i grew up poor and so i was just
fat from eating bad food but now that i
can afford the good food i want to eat i
can't eat it because i'm fat and i gotta
stop eating what do you mean you can't
eat it
so like let's say i really want like
gourmet mac and cheese from astros
it's like forty dollars and everybody
using fries right now okay but tomorrow
when i start my keto i'm gonna have to
eat hard boiled eggs you have your whole
life to eat math shows back into you
that's a good point you're right i think
that mindset
i'm just had to give it up do you have a
napkin
yeah i got several what happened to your
napkin
i just want to ask you for something so
you can hand me through oh yeah it's
kind of fun
thank you i'm so full honestly we ate so
much food today i'm so over it
oh that was so good yeah
well i gotta say what a day it's been
what a day what an episode i mean this
is we put in our hours today we put in
our whole day
it felt like a shoot like a movie shoot
where you like get to set at like 10
and huh we've done it all today
you can see me oh this is a wide angle
can you see my hand
no i won't regret it it's the only thing
is just it's embarrassing i love the car
though
but i'm just slightly embarrassed to be
driving it
because it's like such a flex on the
world yeah okay but think about this but
you just say
you made me do it oh don't put that on
you tell your mom that she's really
gonna hate me forever she already hates
me she's gonna double hate me
too late we're not i'm not coming to
pass over her
just so i know you don't put this in but
not that we're invited
i can't you you're out on my mom yeah
that's so awkward
she's coming she's coming babe i
literally cannot and i told you anyways
this is
outside my mom watches all of our shows
she like knows everything
exactly well that's like ancient mystery
you and the family you gotta have
passover with my mom my mom
oh his mom wait you don't want to meet
his mom what about your [ __ ] mind
you gotta meet him you're not gonna come
to passover with his i'm not gonna
talk about my mom that's insane that's
not even an option no i'm gonna meet his
mom i'm not gonna come to the password
with your mom
oh my mom's the problem okay that's more
fun no because she hates
me so i can't come to a place i'm hated
and your sister could you imagine i just
talked so much
on the first episode i'm not doing it
it's so embarrassing i'm just gonna
expect to become my sister right i'm
embarrassed for myself
right well right is that what you said i
said well
he taught me bro no the
girls are all scared you must know that
i'm non-binary
i don't think he knows that
he's funny you know what i was just a
little sour because
he's the enemy because like were you
doing these hard negotiations are you
giving us all this
oh you don't want me to be frozen i
never heard that word before
you could schmooze i was just like oh
this [ __ ] guy just took me for the
ride of my life
you know what i mean yeah but look at
you got the right of your life from it
not even forever
it was a close call by the way we almost
didn't close the deal there's like a lot
i mean with the rolls-royce why well
because i had to get insurance and then
people didn't want to share such
expensive car and then i had to my
credit card limit wasn't high enough for
the down payment so i had to call the
bank
and then they couldn't raise it on such
a certain notice because the office was
closed
yeah yeah run a credit card check which
would take until like later next week
and so then what we had to do was like
put a little on the card
and a little on this card it's like such
a stretch
and by the way i was gonna if it didn't
fall go through today i was gonna be
like peace out on this machine
of course yeah i would have been too
signed by god [ __ ] you that's like
tomorrow i'll be like
i think better i told him i was like i'm
gonna sleep and when i wake up
i'm not gonna want this car so you
better close this [ __ ] today no you will
i would have walked away i think you'll
be like wow it's a lot but you'll you'll
be happy no i'll be happy i'm just
saying i could have walked away
if it didn't go down tonight
on god as they say i'm so jealous of you
okay this is fine tomorrow tomorrow
i'm gonna be with you i promise you i'm
going to do it with you i promise for
real because i really want you
inspired me wouldn't it be so cool
though like if we got so skinny
yeah if we got done we got super skinny
it's like
but i have so many reasons to dye it
with like my wedding
and my music video i mean no because
it's not healthy keto's going to kill
you with all the cholesterol and so
you don't do it forever you just do it
for like a couple days you don't have to
eat just like
all cholesterol like eggs and spinach i
have like broccoli soup
you know what i mean it's only not
healthy for you but you lose weight well
who says it's healthy
you just said you don't want to die but
you probably will die from keto
uh no i'm gonna die from being a [ __ ]
fat larded dog [ __ ] that's like fifty
percent found
i'm gonna do keto because i have so many
things i have to be so yeah they
seriously give me two creams for a
coffee this size like uh excuse me you
asked for my [ __ ] autograph like you
get four creams
oh wait speaking of coffee can you make
a frenemies mug like the h3 mugs
uh probably i mean yeah of course we can
sure is it hard
it's just i don't know why but when we
were doing the h3 mugs
the i love those books they're my
favorite we had coffee in them yesterday
i don't know what we were doing it
through represent so it wasn't a great
deal we could make them through like
with teddy fresh will be much better
conditions but i love it
even my mom was like oh they should sell
these cups i'm like i know the thing is
we were making like 50 cents for sale
because they were really expensive
and there was really high minimums so
we're like this is just pointless
even though we love them wasn't worth
the effort you know
no we just make them for us no we can
make them for frenemies if we source
them through teddy fish
just because our people are you know i
want the giant mugs you know
madonna has really nice
i'm not dude this is the only time i'm
gonna put down my window
yeah never do i'm never putting down my
window again the internet's gonna come
for you though they got so mad at me
when i rolled up my window when i rolled
out my window for that girl i wanted
food and then i rolled it you did a good
job defending yourself though because
you're like
you went on like a whole thing about how
you never know and i was like
i think you convinced a lot of people no
like literally people get like carjacked
you're right
you're right i you you convinced me i
backed off
that was but that was the most insane
thing i've ever heard people being like
wow you're going to get that person
excuse me what like people thought you
were just like bye homeless
punk oh my god
okay well that was a great app i hope
you guys enjoyed that
long i'm broke now action-packed i'm
[ __ ] thanks trisha
you came into my life they're my
brother-in-law you [ __ ] are in my
house around my son just like you said
you would and now i'm broke because
you're
not numb and [ __ ] dead
oh god what's next i mean you took
everything from me
thank god i'm kidding
probably killed me though that's how
this ends
[Music]
what is
[Laughter]
to end with the cars all right see you
guys next week
[Music]
you